pardon madame est ce que vous auriez dit
francs pour payer le café quoi
pardon monsieur est ce que vous auriez
s'il vous plaît 10 francs pour régler
mon café vous allez auriez vous s'il
vous plaît la modique somme de 10 francs
que j'aime acquis de cette équipe
dix balles vous avez a pas dix ou vingt
balles pour payer le café
réputé comme je suis une bonne part et
vous donnez jamais vraiment c'était
cette fois une bonne idée de venir
prendre un café à chambéry
oui moi dans la mesure où ouais mais
c'est moins prestigieux qu'il ya moins
de blaireaux pour payer la moitié
ailleurs merci madame doit vous avez des
timbres les tickets de métro j'ai du
courrier à faire et on abuse et pas
madame alors bon d'accord merci madame
donnez-moi - 10 balles
évidemment je suis gonflé mais gagner
plein de pognon vous êtes paco rabanne
ou vous êtes bourrés de blé a décroché
un peu de pognon vraiment mal à votre
jeu n'est pas boire de café cher vos
petits ses déboires de riz café à 751
blaireau pour le payer merci monsieur à
merci
excusez moi je me suis trompé ses 20
francs excusez-moi autant pour moi ah
non monsieur ne partez pas sans payer et
à 20 pour le gars fait donc défaut
vienna monnaies vous et que les bars on
soyez sympa donnez-moi 10 francs
dépanner mois et coûté très franchement
c'est la première fois je vous demande
quelque chose
ok je vous ai jamais rien demandé avant
mais moi je faisais jamais rien demandé
avant alors pour une fois je
pour une fois je m'en as a service vous
êtes vraiment pas sympa à mon avis cette
plaine de blé et les bijoux en or vous
acteurs tichy sa branche bon écoutez
j'ai pas le temps payé mon café qu'on en
finisse donc non mais en plus petit
vous êtes le doublé c'est une double et
vous auriez simplement différent pour
laquelle cap et il me manque dit merci
vous êtes bien gentil monsieur gentil
attendait tant des jeux voix vous avez
autant de l'abonné mettez le tout payé
tout ça m'arrange deux pièces de 10
francs
merci monsieur
merci
la bien gentil monsieur merci je vais
régler comme ça
merci monsieur
non
non non ce qu'a fait monsieur pourquoi
merci buengo pardon
mandela monnaie vous montrer le cap et
cette fois ça passe maintenant c'est à
vous je remercie infiniment mieux êtes
bon si tout le monde était comme vous
monsieur en toi même et c'est tout le
monde était comme vous merci messieurs
salles imax
ça va tu verras tu va régler mon café
tabac coeur toi bien là pour vingt
balles max tu as bon coeur prêté à ce
que j'aime angie valve medieval max
tales [ __ ] notre menu venez en foire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus